[Music]
this morning in our series world food we
look at technology that may be the
future of fine dining 3d printers are
being adopted in hospitals auto assembly
lines factories and now a kitchen in an
upscale restaurant Roxana Saberi visited
a new restaurant in the Netherlands
touted not as farm to table but pixels
to plate in the pastures of his parents
farm Yuans Minka top dutch chef is going
back to the basics our typical fish
local ingredients to create a new
culinary future we use it but we
transform it into a little bit modern
fishing modern because he's a pioneer in
printing food then you're gonna bring 3d
printers don't actually cook meals but
they pump pureed ingredients so you're
using cauliflower now to layer upon
layer delicate designs you can make
shapes and what you can't make by hands
like an avocado octopus or meatballs
filled with curry sauce michelin-starred
chefs have printed dishes before and the
University of Utah hospital now prints
meals for patients with problems
swallowing solid food butts mink is the
first to give printed food a permanent
place in each course on the menu
Wyatt 3d food printing something extra
for my guests to to surprise them we
want to give them an extra dimension
does it change the food itself it don't
change anything about the flavor for
example because what you put it into the
printer will come out so if you put
something nice in then you will have
something nice just like regular
printers sometimes what you put into
these printers in this case cauliflower
hazelnut puree and roasted pumpkin
got clogged it stopped just can't jam
and then you have to reboot right just
like computers many restaurants are
scared of Technology in their kitchens
but Lena Hoff says the printer is
provided by her company by flow are
easier to use than many chefs think
you're used to ovens they're used to
pots and pans
and this is the hurdle we have to
overtake mink took a leap earlier this
month that his new restaurant in his
hometown of both ago testing the
technology on friends and me so it's the
celery root that was 3d printed yes
if dishes like these prove popular and
the devices each nearly four thousand
dollars get cheaper pixels to plate
could improve nutrition and fight waste
by transforming unappealing food into
tasty works of art plus it's fun what is
your dream dish that you'd like to make
using one of these printers that we
prints the face of the guests eatable
like a nice flavor and make a dish of it
at the end of the night eat your face as
dessert yeah and if someone don't like
his own face and contains someone who's
looking rising he says if you makes a
dash of inspiration with a touch of
Technology anything's possible for CBS
this morning Roxana Saberi volka the
Netherlands the CBS eye nice chat nice
touch books on it but it seems like
would be slow to do what do you yeah you
guys cook well no I just went to the
makers faire and was well I owned a lot
of these 3d printers they just take a
while so I wonder if that works in sort
of but I'd like any kind of innovation
yeah also I wonder if the taste of toner
would get in there we don't want that no
no no we're not quite at the replicator
yet we're getting